hello I'm James King and welcome to
Vienna Austria for the world premiere of
Mission Impossible rogue nation here at
the State Opera House actually a key
location in Ethan hunts latest action
packed mission now we'll hear from the
stars of the film a little bit later but
first here's how I max transformed this
incredible venue into an actual IMAX
theater for one night only the biggest
challenge was doing it in the time
available it takes us two weeks to
install a system we had a couple days
here to make this happen take your
position I sure was about to start well
I always love is you know giving an
audience the best experience possible
and i believe imax delivers that
considering we're standing in front of
the Vienna State Opera this is a
sequence I'm excited for everybody to
see we were here shooting for five days
and it's a really fun scenes this place
is in the movie it has so much history
Tom said that's what I want to do I want
to put an IMAX theater in the Vienna
Opera House and I think this allows it
to premiere up to the standards that the
movie deserves I think the size of the
stunts and the size of the ambition in
the film you know match the kind of IMAX
experience Hank
this may very well be our last mission
let's make a count it has tremendous
scope and it's an epic story seeing
films on a big screen is great fun it's
also about seeing films together you
ready it's my first massive action
communites astonishing the action is
definitely epic so to see it on a big
screen and have that experience you know
that is that's that's what I want oh my
god